the audio recorded should we be required
to evacuate the building would you
please leave the room by the
door to the fire estate fire escape
staircase
please both hold hands both hand rails
in case the stairs
are wet or slippery if anyone is unable
to use the stairs would they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door
where they can then be given assistance
our assembly point will be in the public
car park
the side of the civic suite please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so
by council staff
right apologies for absence should i
just read them out
we have apologies from uh
jerry gibson mrs leslie butcher george
iono
michael webb john hater and robin drive
non-members attending that's relative to
maddox
uh the minutes of the meeting held on
the 2nd of february 2016. can i
sign those up thank you very much
to receive any declarations of interest
that's an interest not interesting okay
um moving on into item number five
doesn't assume would do anything
[Music]
um i don't quite know where we go
with some of this because the report
that uh paulus
has produced for us to my mind is
is quite comprehensive the conclusions
are pretty well
stated as far as i'm aware um
i have nothing really to add to what
paul has already reported for us
um does anybody else want to go in and
then we'll see where we spin off from
that john
thank you
page 5.1 there are apparently 252
enforcement cases outstanding
etcetera etcetera i remember a couple of
years ago
in successive years councillor black
stood and asked a question in full
council
i think the first time he asked the
questions in excess of 500
i think the second time he asked it was
about 452
so i'm a little bit of a loss to
understand how we managed to divest
ourselves of
such a large number at least 200 uh over
the back period
and i just wonder what we did because if
we did something really good
then why don't we do it again perhaps i
just signed them off
but i agree with them
do you want me just yeah yeah i did
do a little bit of digging uh council
16 december 2014 when council black
asked the question the last time
the number of cases in hand were 362.
the scorecard that reports the
performance figures
they seem to have been closing off about
20 a month
from what i can see but
i can't give you any further details on
that
so
i've got a funny feeling that
they were coming up to for you
and that we haven't taken any action so
they just fell off anyway
because they've been there for years i
really don't know
i i really can't i can't throw any light
onto that john
i don't know if there is
i mean what what are we going to achieve
if if we
do try and do this because the people
that probably would have known the
answers are no longer with us i think
what we need to do
is make sure that now that we are
until may the review committee that we
have things in place that they won't
just fall off the bottom and we don't
know what the answer is
can i come back yeah yeah if i might
yeah um what i don't know from this
report
is how many of them
approaching the four-year mark anyway
and it doesn't say anywhere in here
but those are going to be looked at as a
priority there is prioritization
but it doesn't say anything about time
limited issues surely it's something
does it say something else
no but oh good no i'm getting quite
worried
so yeah what i would say is
one of the recommendations is members
should receive a quarterly
report on outstanding enforcement cases
which okay it's not going to tell us
what they've
put in in the last year
but it will give us a base point to go
forward from and to see what items are
so we'll have something like date added
to the
to the list when saturn
statutory expires
in our recommendations if this is
something we specifically
want in we ask for what we want on the
reportedly report
it's as simple as that that's what i was
going to say if you want to tweak
the recommendation to include the
information you want i can't
record that i like that one i mean it
shouldn't be that
difficult to say you know first first
recording
science oh review bang project or i mean
if i i don't i don't have any
reason to assume that we shouldn't ask
for this some of this information
if the answer comes back well can we get
away with can we just give you x y and
say everything's down to us to say yes
or no
it's as simple as that and if we don't
like what's being presented and we
we want to address it again and we
revisit it then we revisit it but i
think
you know perhaps we could just if
necessary paul
um either i'll talk to christine or you
can talk to christine just
you know see what her ideas are where we
say
that you know we're going to get a
quarterly report
what what what basic requirements were
first
first registered i think just tweak the
recommendation to include the data you
want
and then that way then what is this
i mean is that data that you
specifically wanted now we're doing it
now and then we've got it covered i
think
dave date added to the list or whatever
we call it
registers it really um the time it
statutorily expires yeah because you
don't know
no that from the date it's been added um
what the breach is in very brief terms
you can
work out the number of words or letters
if you like yeah
and um what action is planned i suppose
yeah but what stage are we at
john um dave have a deterrent factor
if this was on the web pages
i think you're opening a can of worms
john potentially because
we don't know what the
legal implications could potentially be
by doing something like that
yeah i didn't mean to sort of highlight
any individual cases
but just have the uh basic numbers
are what the numbers of of cases
outstanding
and and the enforcement rates and
successful cases well we can do
i mean i have no strong i mean
the the the information will be
available to councillors
excuse me if if members of the public
want to know well then we
we could be able to find it for them i
mean i i
i i i'm not quite sure what's what would
be achieved by about you've got yeah
um on the michelin farm
report the recommendation is for a
quarterly
report as well i did type them in yeah
and that was to go to council
so it would be a public it'd be
available to
most authorities do it that way okay
that's very nothing
yeah i think the difference is we've
never done anything like this so
whatever we do is going to be an
improvement on what we've had before
yeah questing can i just say that when
we
get this report could we have not only
when if it's solved
but the ones that we lose because their
time expired
because i think that's that's the issue
that we're
seeing that has possibly and probably
happened that the greater reduction in
numbers hasn't been because of any
uh greater activity in our offices past
because our officers have actually
reduced in number
so it would be unrealistic to expect
them to do more work when there's less
of them
however if basically we're putting
things into enforcement letting them sit
there for four years and they're saying
oh that's right that's going away
it's not really that the intention of
reinforcement so perhaps if we could
have
whether they're solved or expired or in
hand
and perhaps also ones that are coming up
for expiry
surely they should be a priority for the
officers if they're within say six
months of
the expiry date of the enforcement
because we have so many i mean we know
in our world we've got so many
situations
where we've had planning breaches we've
had enforcement notices
and oh too late are we
are we prevention rather than cure going
forward but are we at risk of
you know we've asked the uh new
senior officer to come away with a
proposal of how they're going to do this
and by putting so much on this and she's
spending going to spend time
researching all this and giving us all
the background are we actually going to
have a detrimental effect on her doing
what is currently
needs addressing quite urgently now
because she's going to spend time
or when somebody's going to spend time
collating this
reporting this and if they're doing that
there's a good chance that we're
actually going to take them away from
the operational stuff i can come back
and
they should be able to pull this off of
any report that they've got this this
information
should be there they should be able to
pull that off their computer systems
if they can't there's something
fundamentally wrong with what they're
doing
because all we're asking for is a date i
think john said when it's
registered how long it's been there not
we're not asking for a full report on
each item we're just saying
you know case number perhaps address
when will it expire that that that
information should be no
i thought you wanted to know where they
dropped off before
no no no going forward oh you'll find
yourself no no no no
not in the past no no no no no no sorry
we need to know we've got 252 we need to
know
say it comes back at 230. we need to
then know
if those 32 have been sold
if they've been resolved or if they've
time expired
and that they also should be a
consideration to priority
on those that are near i don't think we
have to
want to tell the officers to do that i
think we should ask them to consider
prioritizing those cases that are near
to time expiring
well i would assume that if they
regarded them as a serious enough event
they would do that with their own
professional standards
well i'm not going to comment on that
mike was first
when you were talking at the beginning
um the thing the thing that came to my
mind was that
most of these things as you've been
discussing would probably be on some
sort of excel package
you know and these things are going
entered and they
and they would produce effects and
figures that you're talking about
but i would like to have seen um just a
list if you like of what those
complaints are
because how can we make a judgment it's
always saying oh they've done 20 21
balls in the park or something huge you
can't make comparisons unless you know
what they're dealing with
and so you can't it's always sound
prioritized they might i'm not certainly
suggesting they do this but they could
prioritize according to what's easier
for them
and rather than what is what we're
saying conversation jack well i did
is a priority what they think she made
it very clear at the various meetings we
attended
christine lyons how they would
prioritize
various issues and that they would have
a set
plan and that's the plan they would work
to and
that if something came up that they had
to rejoice
yes they would now how do we review that
plan if we don't know what it
what they're dealing with because
they're doing it on a quarterly basis to
tell us what it is now
if it says an address we don't know all
the ins and outs of it we have to leave
them to prioritize that's what why
they're the officers understand
what i'm saying is what i'm trying to
say is if we was to get i
of whatever those complaints are
whatever they are regardless of the
severity
and as you quite rightly say there's
sort of some sort of time factors
involved in this
um we can look at that and we can make a
judgment about that
so you're going to tell the officers now
to prioritize
no no i'm just saying i can't sit here
and say oh
like you were saying there's a hundred
gone whoops yeah but we've gone through
that jack
now we're going we're talking about how
the information we're going to try and
collect in future
we know we've got to answer some of the
questions here where have they gone
since the 252
but what we're trying to do is establish
a procedure
so that when this report comes through
you can look at it and say right
that one's due to expire in 18 months
that one's expired so and so
they prioritize hopefully they'll give
us a list of what their priorities are
and then we can if we need to ask them
questions on that report that's
that's what it says in the report on 3.8
new inquiries
will be triaged yeah triage means you
put the most important first
the less important love it says like
yeah perhaps i'm not getting myself
across too well all i'm saying is i
schedule i'm not asking for detailed
information asking for their work that
calls on
i'm just talking about a schedule of
what they are that's what we're
discussing
or um over-extension or
something otherwise we can't make a
judgment can you
so are we now questioning their triage
scenario
particularly yeah well we can't if that
is that if that's what you're asking to
do
you're already i'll say you'll be you've
got a new
person coming in situ who we haven't
seen an operation
and you're questioning their operation
in my mind now i've got
no big axe to grind on this i just want
the thing to work as efficiently as we
can
but we haven't even seen we haven't even
given us three months of the system that
we've
agreed to put in place yet well i'll
hold my breath and won't achieve it
well i mean i think if if we get the
information we can ask questions on the
information we receive
but i think we've you know we we're sort
of undermining the
the officers assessment of work if we're
saying well we
you know i think this one should be more
important than that one and i think
and we're all going to have our two
pennyworth which they made it clear that
if we had a particular case they would
listen to it
there's no reason why you can't approach
somebody jack if you are
she made it clear at the meeting that if
you're not happy or you want to register
or express concern about something you
can
there's no there's no problem with that
at all
i want to say i'm i had no i'm
only chairing this meeting to to come up
with some conclusions we've drawn up
what we think is right but
i think before we see we before we see
anything we're almost undermining what
we're going to see well we haven't seen
it yet
that's why until we see and then ask the
questions if we don't get the answers
that we expect or we hope for when we
get our first
quarterly report then we then we start
saying well this is not what we're
expecting yes
perhaps a way of resolving this and i
can see both sides of the difficulty and
i can see what
i actually agree with what jack's saying
but i agree with what you're saying
i don't think you're miles apart but
what we've got in here at 5.2 is the
propose that the committee resolves to
receive an update on planning
enforcement is
in six months time you're saying
culturally report
so why don't we remove that to three
months
and then we've got a shorter time scale
if it's not going
how we like we've got an opportunity to
suggest that
it's tweaked and that seems to
cut you know be a compromise and cover
what you both want
instead of six months do it three months
you were saying about closed ones
with the list okay the quarterly list
do you would you like it to include
closed ones and how they were closed and
i think that would then cover your point
yeah yes oh yes definitely whether
they've been sold because it's been
resolved
yeah whether it be yes and they got to
resolution can we just award to it as
well
yeah mike sorry you want to come yeah um
the report is okay so far as it goes a
bit
surprised there's a little bit of lack
of detail in certain areas
um and i was rather disappointed that
there's no target being set to to reduce
them by or how many they
would aim to get done per month i think
this was made quite clear mike
when she said that just because it was
an easy write-off
didn't mean to say that that was the
priority one to do she could write off
20 of them 30 of them
but that wasn't the right but that's the
point i'm trying to make before the same
yeah she made that very clear
and i agree however possibly it's come
down because they've been concentrating
on the easy ones that's fine
which makes me worried about how many
the 252 actually complex funds anyway at
the moment
um i just want to come to the point back
to this reporting report we're getting
as all councillors will be getting is um
around these minor infringements
are minor infringements going to be left
off the list or that will they know
they will be they will be on the list
and they'll be marked as minor
but we go back to this same scenario of
the triage
if it's i think i understand that you
don't have to explain that yeah
i want to know if they're on the list
they're on the list and they'll be um
yes so effectively they're going to be
ones not which will not be
being done yeah but uh i
i i think she made it very clear that
she could clear off probably
20 by just writing them off and saying
that you know x y and zed
but that is not trying to do that if
they're picking
they are having 30 per month they should
be a target that they should be
expecting to do per month they're not
going to be easy ones are they
no i i thought i would do 30 a month or
i want to get all three in a month
i think they have a far different
approach to be honest
yeah so there's no car guess fine no i
just want to make the point
um with regards to the number of
officers how many officers are there and
there's no mention of their numbers in
here
there were one and a half there wasn't
is probably as many as all or more than
in the past so i'm not sure why they
think it's been
reduced i think it once does it went
down to one and a half it was one and a
half
i think that there is in here in the
report that
she felt she needed more very possibly
bob just for make the point
it comes across that there are more of
um fewer officers now but i think
that it has been threatened it was quite
a long time ago
um when nick retired yeah you went yeah
you've gone moved down one and a half
for a while then yeah so if we get a
three monthly review and it looks like
that the
progress isn't as we'd anticipate then
that's something that
could be considered but until i don't
think until we get the first review
in three months we can i think we've
already
expressed concern christine on this
number of staff and in other areas that
if we expect us
to reduce the results that we want
we ain't likely to get it with the
number of people that we've got
currently employed in various positions
whether it be in here
or in the accounts and i think we've
made these points of already another
review area well certainly on audio we
have john
we're currently running i had a
conversation with uh
quite recently and it was only in
passing i believe we're
running 30 fte below um
full strength and normally you'd carry
forward those as vacancies but they've
not been made vacancies they've been
leveled
it's been leveled for budgetary and
other purposes so
if you if if the department wish you an
assistant director's department
wants to add another member of staff on
then a case has to be made
and of course it will be tabbed against
the uh the 30
but we were running under budget as um
in response to the risk-free structure
these are people that left as part of
the restructure these people who chose
to leave
i don't know you've got more insight
with that than i had
yeah one other question around the
report
um it does make mention of the
the new building that's going to be
happening in the district and that would
yeah
mean that they'll be in for obviously
there's an expectation that's going to
be enforcement cases is there and
was there an idea put forward how many
new cases that might
lead to because they'll be over and
above i don't we've been experiencing
risks
i don't think there was a number
anticipated
it's just anticipated it would lead to
some yes i think i think well i think
she was
i think she was quite uh i think
christine's point was particularly down
the london road she drives past it every
day and i think their attitude was
you know i'll be watching this on my
on my way in or on my way home and
as a should we say almost a daily brief
but
yes i think she does anticipate some
problems but she hoped
i think that they can eliminate a lot of
them with
dealing with the building contractors
beforehand or
in other areas but yes there will be i
think
i think we're all pretty aware that
eventually there are issues
that have been left unfortunately i
believe
so i think it's good that she's picking
up on that
yeah i don't i don't think that no
i think i certainly didn't get the
impression that you know that though
you should just give them a free hand
and letting loose nonsense it's good
that she
is changing the attitude of the council
in regard to enforcement
in that area have we got now sorry jack
yeah
um i just want to just clarify for my my
own
310 on page five two um it goes on there
about
it says some minor breaches for example
nobody fences over two meters of minor
domestic violence will be considered
against set criteria
and in most cases no action taken um
and he says no further action will be
taken by the team i'm just curious of
going back to what was said earlier
about where
the numbers how they're sort of like
reduced down
on this list we're getting well they
sort of identify these things without
any involvement in other percent
oh that's a three meter fence it fits
the criteria we're not taking the action
from the outset
would that list show that or did you
think they'll go out and talk to the
people
i mean focus they're just going to say
that's not what you want what do you
want what sort of requirements
is it investigated or not investigated
well that would be triage you might say
not a priority that's my point yeah i
know what i'm saying so just put a clip
for me
that so that it comes in let's put it
away
sit there they say no that's not a
priority it's three hours at that point
boom no
no action but it will still be recorded
yeah i would like to know because
they're not coming out of balanced view
see what what they are looking at and
what they're not looking at okay well
like that that's how
i would understand it is my
interpretation that they would triage
that okay
well it's just a balance of workload and
stuff like that see
but i mean i think i can understand a
basis that got limited resources and and
that they will prioritize
what is the big the big problems if if
you're gonna
let something happen that is gonna have
a huge effect on
a town center a building development or
whatever
that is your priority the three foot
and that's i think is as simple as it it
gets jack that's what she's trying to
make sure they do
but she's not just going to keep writing
off cases you could do that
she told us that but she will go through
them and triage them
and not just write them off because it's
a nice easy way to reduce the numbers
perhaps i'll be in china i
i say i think you have to you have to
give
you have to give the new person in
charge
i'll give them do i give them all the
credit for that don't get me wrong i'm
not saying that it's just
how i perceive this in the sense that if
that knowledge gets
out and we put our planning in and
everything else he gets for the proof
and then someone put say well don't
worry we've got two and a half foot
fence up there turn off me offense
because we know we're getting away with
that
it sort of sends a signal but i think i
think there was also
a a set view on some of these issues
that it's not going to be as it was in
the past
you have a letter if you don't respond
in seven days you will get something
else
if you don't do that it's not going to
be
just allowed to drift as perhaps some of
them have getting past that
that's my understanding of what what is
intended
quite quite systematic quite precise
the way i read this paper in that
particular point
is that people will be told residents
will be told
where they're in breach of planning and
they'll be told that they need to put in
a planning application that in itself
means when they come to sell their home
they are in breach of planning and
they'll find a huge amount of difficulty
in selling their property
i think that's probably in some cases
realistic
are there any more issues that we need
to put into this
conclusion can we can we put those in
for yeah
what do we need to do now to to to tie
all these recommendations
in then all right so recommendation
number one we'll tweak it
to include the headings that you want
i they added to list time
statutory expires what breach is what
action is planned the ward
and we'll also have a closed cases
section
and report with the reason of how it was
closed
yeah well it will be shown yeah
um isn't this the reason why we've got
these officers
to make those uh decisions for us
um surely we're not in the position to
say
you can not close this spin off and you
can close that one off
what is the point of having if we can
allow them to do that
i understand about i report but are you
really expecting us to go through 370
issues every couple of months and decide
whether it's right for them to make that
decision or wrong
i mean what's the point of implying them
if you're going to do that
surely there must be a bit of um we're
employing them
because we think they're good at their
job and they can do the things that they
should be doing
um a bit of fencing is that really an
issue
when you say have a hundred houses that
shouldn't be there
surely we should be prioritizing it so
that
we are taking the big issues but the
little issues
surely it's it's a minor thing
but why do we need to know if somebody's
got a six foot
fence instead of a six foot six sense
surely the priority should be the
the large developments and that large
extensions that are causing
a lot of the people out there the
headaches they're not concerned about a
fence being bigger than it is or
a little bit of that they're little
there but i think i think
what was was that we were going to
register all the applica all the
requests that come in and then they
would triage them
and we would see where they're going to
how they're going to control them
we're not telling them which ones
they've got to triage in which they've
got to take the priority on
all we want you to know is how many have
you had in this month
and they're they're going to dictate
which of the top 30 not us
i think as well it's a bit planning
there are so many planning issues
that can make the list endless and
consequently i think
what's not in this it's 252 i told you
how many there are yeah well 200
352 on a a4 sheet or
half a dozen a4 sheets what are we going
to learn from this is a couple of minor
and a couple of major well what we're
going to learn is that office
members want to know what's going on
okay fine tell if you don't want to
don't read it
yeah well no but i i just can't wait
personally but as a ward member if i am
re-elected
i should be very interested in going
down their list and looking at the
places
that are in my ward and and getting an
assurance that uh
planning is being complied with you know
completely and actually
in terms of breaches or bridges of
condition and
to be quite honest if i feel that you
know something is wrong and it hasn't
been properly looked at
and as a war member and not at the full
council meeting
it will be beforehand i've spoken to the
head of planning
and asked her why that particular item
didn't receive the attention that i
expected
that's that's not normally what board
members do
i spend quite a long you know a bit of
time actually listening to residents
who who do report breaches of planning
that's where most of these
things come from it doesn't come from
our offices driving past development
it actually comes from members of the
public who noticed something that's
wrong
well let's i think we
i think we've highlighted all the issues
that we want to issue
to to highlight on this one if we can
put that into
our recommendations paul yeah and
i don't know if you want to run this
past christine and say look this is what
we're going to ask for
so in future this is where you've got to
gear yourself up to supply this
information
this is what the what the members want
so
if she's getting getting a package
together of how she's going to present
it she
she knows what we're going to be looking
for chairman i
don't see any reason why if i was
managing this myself or indeed
christine's managing on her behalf that
she wouldn't want this information
as a management control anyway and i'm
rather surprised if you like
that there isn't attached to this uh a
current position of the 252 anyway
which kind of suggests to me that we
don't have that control as present
and it's being put in place it may well
be the question may well be the case but
we've got it this is going to be our
recommendations now
yeah okay and yeah mr chairman of five
two is going to be three months
yeah yeah okay okay yeah
excellent right
that was the easy one no it wasn't
that was chunky
right mislin's farm
[Applause]
well i'm i'm not quite some of you guys
were around here long before i wasn't
saw this one running
and running and running
you know we've made our recommendations
on page 6.4
can we work back from that
we use that as our baseline and
ask in line of all the meetings we've
had the reports we've had
and one thing and another we've had the
the uh was it lincolnshire was it
lincolnshire agreement
that we we suggested that we looked at
and as
we used as a base for the district and
essex to use together
can we start on on five on
recommendation or
item five for the recommendations and
see
what we don't agree with or if we want
to amend any of that
john i think i would just like to say
that we've had quite a few meetings it's
three isn't it
meaning more yeah yeah i think it's
three uh the last one
um we actually came up with what some
actually on the
paragraph five of his recommendations
yeah uh it was no surprise to me
to find these written there um they're
exactly as we last met
um you're quite right to ask if any
members are now at second thoughts
but i'd be very interested if any
members have got second thoughts
because i think it's what we ask for
thank you because let's
you know say let's start there we're not
going to go through all the reports and
everything else again these are the
recommendations
is has anybody got anything they want to
add challenge
or whatever can i just say
yeah i've got some concerns because
going past it
this morning and yesterday i noticed
note that the thinking that the tires
are still there
and a huge pile of more rubbish has been
done there
so i don't know what this feeling have
we learned anything at all
because i've taken a picture of very
good picture but
there's a huge amount of more rubbish
now
appeared on the site and than before
so i i'm i'm i'm a bit of a ghost too
and there's the picture and the land's
up for sale right
brian as i believe we've already spoken
to
planning enforcement and reported it
what and they told me this morning you
had
it's alright um
now i'm told that it's an amount of
plasterboard
it's it's been flyer tipped
bold accounts they lifted the gate off
the hinges drove it
dumped it and drove off again and
there's a police
investigation on it at the moment the
environment agencies evolved
and so is our planning enforcement i
didn't know that but
i thought so
then looking into it
two things if i make just for
information really firstly
is i think i've already mentioned this
is i've had an inquiry about that then
from
quite a lot of vicious men but um the
point is while it sits there
well we're just monitoring it basically
not well that we are the agencies are
and until someone does something with
this land if this is going to be an
ongoing exercise
we could be sitting here next year i'm
told the gate is now
padlocked so it can't be lifted off
but they are in actively trying to sort
this out
unless there's a large pile of tires
from the original
um fire which is still there ready to be
set alive again
and causing the same effect as the last
one you don't know that
it's remarkable how they can be left to
do that
that's right remind us of the scope of
the
the actual business or review committee
on this particular subject
is it to take regular reports and
consider what action we should be taking
although we've got professional officers
to do that or are we considering
the policy of the council towards
issuing the
particular issues of michelin star and
more particularly
how we're going to manage or how we
expect the council
to manage this by policy in the future
well that was my understanding john
that this is we've tried to learn from
what's gone on in the past
and put in place a joint approach
to what is going to go on in the future
and that's what we've said here
joining for joining the enforcement
protocol is agreed with essex county
council and the environment agency
so that we we do this
um and again according to the update
reinforcement cases present to full
council
so you know we put these issues in place
um
i don't i don't know what else we can
what else you want me to do brian to be
honest
no no i'm just staggered by the fact
that it's been brought to the attention
because
this particular michelin's farm
and one the initial problem hasn't been
resolved
because the ties are still late and
what's making it even worse
is getting more and more stuff is being
done there which
it makes it faster job i like you know i
just
but it's amazing that it can carry on
it makes a boss okay i thought john
wanted to come in first
yeah i i only want to say to him i'm
sure
we all know of other areas that are
suffering from environmental damage
um i mean i've got now got involved in
an issue in watts lane in rockford
because
you know a member of the public asked me
to
assist the ward members in doing
something about it but equally i don't
expect to bring it to this committee
to to discuss it unless it appears on
that enforcement list
or is one of those particular cases
where there are significant issues that
are in joint enforcement and we need to
do something about
is there any more we can do as a review
committee other than
with the recommendations we've made i'll
be i'll be guided by you paul no no i
don't think right so
no i agree with them john i think the
recommendation is what we ask for
i might suggest that um the um quarterly
update would include
michelin's farm on it no doubt and that
way councillor hayes would be able to
work
he should be there exactly we're all
going to be looking for it
so we've got to follow through that goes
on so you that report may be useful
to council hazelwood after all welcome
uh
john christine you're probably going to
answer this for me i think i know the
answer anyway
the land is up for sale someone buys it
are the conditions set to that purchase
yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that that
cannot be changed
the the conditions on it will be
transferred
and made particularly known to the new
one yeah you new owner will have
you know we'll have the environment
agency and the other agencies involved
um they will reiterate what actions need
to be taken
and hopefully um they won't require
enforcement action to finish it
i agree with what he's saying yeah and
that's what i thought it would be it's
just that i got something from
essex county council and let's say it's
here say
and it's not going to happen so we'll
carry on as we do
okay or a bad thing
i think the only thing that i've
believed i'm not sure if i'm right here
don't worry correct me if i'm not
is that though the conditions prevail
the enforcement
action has to restart if there's a
change of ownership so
so from that point of view yes you've
got your conditions you've been
without preempting further disasters can
we
finalize our recommendations on this one
before we have to start addressing the
next
scenario so if there's no
no other comments to make on this we'll
go along with
what's there paul okay if everybody's in
agreement
thank you right
um here we go key
decision documents
is
okay the first item 1515 response to
essex county council
consultation on the waste local
clan that's been on there for a couple
of months
um 1615 the trees
that's also been on there for a couple
of months and
soon hopefully those reports should come
out
and then we've got two new ones
um one the planning policy evidence base
for the south essex strategic housing
market assessment
and then the draft homeless strategy
for 216 to 21.
[Music]
there was one this is one that i think
going through this one there's been some
work on it and she's just trying to
finalize it and
get it sorted out so she's got the
documents
that
and moving on to the work plan um
you'll see we've got fusion lifestyle
come to the april meeting and
there'll be the annual report and i also
believe
that the treasury management will be
revisited
[Applause]
i think they're coming back with some
portfolio
examples so i believe that's what
they're going to do
but i haven't seen anything to be able
to
sort of hand on heart you will also see
this
um work items for next year
if anybody's got any more suggestions
please let me have them
well perhaps yeah i mean by all means
but i mean we may not be here next year
paul
you know we we don't know if we're going
to be elected so
you might want someone to carry on yeah
oh yeah i mean but
um if there's yeah by all means if
there's anything that
um that people would like to put forward
but i think
actually we you know it might be more
appropriate
the new people that come in dictate what
they want to
what they feel is appropriate because
their ideas of what is a priority may
not be the same as
by all means if there's more things that
people want to put on but then
it will be down to the new committee to
decide what they
prioritize or treat if i may
um but i might be completely out of gear
on this one but
as it's meant asset management the kid
learned a lot about the assets and about
the reviews they're looking at assets
and so on
and i just wondered if it would be
interesting to look at
what about the assets and what we what
their intention is to do with the assets
and follow me because before i keep you
in bed we're looking at assets every
year it's about assets
well there's supposed to be as far as
i'm aware there might be
there is a supposed to be a report
coming out shortly
the portfolio holder for enterprise who
is also the chair of the investment
board
is chairing a um as a leading
a work stream to look at all of the
assets in
in a number of ways and that is due to
report out in the first half
of the municipal year i'm fairly content
that that's being looked at in depth and
i don't think the new committee need to
do it as well
but as always if um members of the
review committee see something they
don't like and then come out of it
holes are left and they you know there's
no other ways of filling them bring it
to a review commission yeah
be quite right i think yeah yes
john said and also that the review
committee did different assets um last
year yes
for what it was worth most of it
thank you very much i think they
conclude to work home yes john
um the ravy area action plan
i understand essex highways have fallen
back on some of their
um proposals and plans that they had
yep as far as yeah the
problem with traffic congestion and the
traffic emissions were you listening
earlier
i'm not proposing radius turned into a
new uh
vibrant healthy new town
do we need to revisit the rainy area
action plan
i think we can question why we haven't
seen anything but i think that
question's already been asked by lots of
other people
right it's going to well you know i mean
is there anything that we can gain by
putting it on review
at johnson when i i think not i think
you'll be being the
counselor it would be an excellent
question to ask at next school council
if you haven't held and heard anything
yeah i mean i say we we've all been
i think everybody here at one time
another has raised yeah
what's going on with the radio and
rochford and hockley
likewise have asked the same questions
but
it doesn't seem to be i don't think
anybody's got anything constructive to
be reported to us john
i thought they were um waiting for
council hudson's
um who had made a proposal at the
highways
panel to um look at it again
um because the proposal that he had put
in
had been forgotten or not picked up on
and they were looking at that well
again before they make
okay fine uh thank you and and i think
we'd all be pleased to see
somebody or hear somebody pull yes even
if there's nothing to report some light
it takes a long time it'd be better than
the council of goldberg
thank you very much indeed